[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه حيث
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
العفو الدوليه تقول ان الامن الايراني قتل
44 طفلا خلال ثلاثه اشهر من الاحتجاجات
سلطات اردنيه
استهدفت مركز المدينه ب 20 صاروخا من نوع
دراد
واشنطن تعلنوا عن توجهي وفد رفيع المستوى
الى الصين ضمن جوله تشمل كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان
فرنسا تتغلب على انجلترا وتواجه المنتخب
المغربي الاربعاء المقبل في نصف النهائي
المونديال
اهلا بكم اعلانات منظمه العفو الدوليه
انها وثقت اسماء 44 طفلا قتلوا خلال
الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه في الانتفاضه في
ايران كما اعلنت المنظمه عن ممارسه العنف
الشديد على اسري 13 طفلا من هؤلاء وذلك من
قبل النظام الايراني بالاعتقال وتهديد
بالقتل وفقا لتقرير العفو الدوليه فقد تم
قتل 34 من هؤلاء الاطفال بالرصاص الحي
واربعون بطلقات الخرطوش وخمسون بالضرب
بالحراوات وطفل واحد بالغاز الموسيقي
للدموع
توتو
[موسيقى]
تمام للغرزه دي طنط ههه
ينضم الينا في استوديو الباحث والخبير في
الشان الايراني صالح حميد اهلا بك معنا
سيد صالح في استديوهات العربيه في الرياض
اذا قتل للاطفال ضرب للاطفال اعتقال اين
المجتمع الدولي والمنظمات الدوليه من
الانتهاكات التي تحدث في ايران
لازال النظام يستمر في هذا العنف ضد
الاطفال حتى يوم امس عندما زار معاون
السلطه القضائيه الايرانيه كاظم وادي
السجن طهران الاصلاح قال انه التقى ب 20
معتقلا دون سن 18 يعني في سجن اصلاح واحد
هناك 20 شخص تحت سن القانونيه وتحت جزء
ثلاثه اشهر منذ اندلاع همم هذه الاحتجاجات
فقط وانما عائلات هؤلاء المعتقلين القتله
يتم تهديدهم يتم همم يعني تره صحيح من ان
يتحدث او يعبر عن حزنه عن حزنهم عن
فقدانهم حتى لا يسلم لكي يدفنوها ويقيموا
مراسم تشييع اشترط عليهم الا يحضروا الناس
وان يتم دفنهم بالخفاء طبعا هذه هذا الرقم
44 طفل فقط ما استطاعت العفو الدوليه
توثيقه منظمات حقوقيه ايرانيه تقول ان
العدد فاقد 65 طفلا تحت سن
الدوليه
يعني البيانات التي صدرت من همم مثلا همم
الطفوله في الامم المتحده اليونيسف وغيرها
همم ليست كافيه يجب ان تكون هناك اجراءات
همم اكثر همم حازم وصرامه همم يجب ان تفعل
اللجنه التي شكلها مجلس حقوق الانسان
عندما اصدار القرار همم
لجنه حقائق تذهب الى ايران تستطيع الدول
الاوروبيه الضغط في هذه الاتجاه الان نرى
مواقف متشدده من خاصه بريطانيا فرنسا
والمانيا حتى شخصيات مثل شولسه المستشار
الالماني الذي كان يعتبر من المقربين من
النظام الايراني الان اتخذ مواقف مغايره
جدا
ويدعو للضغط على النظام لوقف الاعدامات
والانتهاكات تؤثر هل تؤدي الى اي تغيير في
الداخل الايراني من قبل النظام
سابقا كان يعول على انه يستطيع من خلال
القمع في الداخل وصمت المجتمع الدولي ان
يقمع هذه الانتفاضه لكن الان انه همم
الموقف مختلف الموقف الدولي موقف مددد غير
مساند همم هناك يعني وسائل الاعلاميه تغطي
هذه الاحتجاجات الايرانيه في الخارج
يستمرون في همم الخروج من مظاهرات
واعتصامات هذه كلها بالطبع لها تاثير على
موقع لان النظام كان همم يعتقد انه سيفلت
من العقاب مثل كل مره لكن الوضع مختلف نرى
ان همم يعني همم سواء بالنسبه للداخل
والخارج المواقف
متشدده جدا ضده ايضا همم يعني رغم انه
يستمر
بالاعدامات وبالترهيب وبالخوف ويصدر
المزيد من الاحكام ويدافع عنها ما تزال
الجماهير تخرج للشهر الثالث على التوالي
ولذلك همم يعني من الممكن ان تؤدي هذه
الاحتجاجات الى اتساع اكبر والى بقاء
الناس في الشارع الان ما هذا ما يدعو اليه
النشطاه هو البقاء والاستمرار لشال حركه
النظام وتشتيت قوه الضغوطات الدوليه
والاحتجاجات الداخليه كيف تقيم سيد صالح
يعني وضع النظام الايراني حاليا بين
التخبط من التهدئه التي باءت بالفشل وبين
التصعيد من قتل المتظاهرين واعدامهم
الحقيقه هناك انقسام ايضا داخل النظام حول
كيفيه التعاطي مع هذه الانتفاضه حتى راينا
يعني شخصيات مقربه من المرشد من عائلته
يعني اخته
واولادها
شخصيات اصلاحيه قاده الحركه الخضراء هناك
حتى يعني همم عسكريين انشقوا من النظام
يعني النظام نفسه من خلال تسريبات وكاله
فارس اعترف بانه اكثر من 150 عسكري بينهم
ضباط كبار معتقلين لانهم اصطفوا الى جانب
همم الناس الحقيقه هذا شرخ يعني غير مسبوق
داخل النظام لكن لا تزال هناك يعني همم
المواقف الدوليه غير واضحه المجتمع الدول
وخاصه الدول الغربيه تتبرع بانه ليس هناك
بديل جاهز همم تشتيت المعارضه بعض
القوانين
ايضا البسيج واعضاء الحرس الثوري وشعرهم
بالضغط والارهاق من كل ذلك شكرا لك
للانضمامك معنا في الاستديو الباحث في
الشان الايراني صالح حميد
ننتقل بكم مباشره مشاهدينا الى جلسه
الحوار الثانيه لملتقى الميزانيه السعوديه
لعام 20 30 20 23 لنستمر
ومن يشاهدنا اليوم كيف كنا في ابريل 20 20
وكيف انتقلنا من من تلك الفتره الحرجه
الصعبه
الى ما نحن فيه الان وايضا بمجمل التحديات
اللي تعرضنا لها خلال الثلاث سنوات تقريبا
لا اربعه اشهر
من
تقلبات حاده سواء في الاسواق بشكل عام
وكم منظمين او هذا ما نسى علاج
بالاسواق
مثل ما يسوون
بالبنوك المركزي
انه ما يهمنا في الاساس هو الحد من
التقلبات ما كان ذلك ممكنا لانه ليس هناك
خدمه افضل للقطاع صناعه الطاقه بشكل عام
البترول الا هو انه يكون عندنا تصور
مستقبلي اكثر استقرار واقل تقلبات فيه مما
يساهم في تعزيز فرص الاستثمار وتمكين
القطاع في الاستمراريه
وفي انه يكون في موضوع في الرؤيه
المستقبليه وبالتالي يكون معزز اللي همم
العمل الجماعي يتوجب يستوجب التوافق
ولذلك من الاساس كنت ومازلت وسوف ابقى مصر
على انه اعطاء كل دوله من دول اوبك بلس
سواء كان حجم منتجه صغير او كبير حقها
فينه تمارس حقها بانها تكون صاحبه القرار
وجزء من منظومه القرار
وهذا الحقيقه اعنا كثيرا في البدايه وحتى
الان في ان همم
نعزز من الثقه الداخليه في نفس المنظومه
نفسها بيننا كدول وبين المشاركين في
اوروبا
يكون يحصل الموضوع في يعني تجمع بين كبار
والباقين يكون محيدين لا دار لهم ولا قيمه
ولا همه
هذا
وين صغرت بعد يعني
احجام انتاج الدول الا انه كان معزز كبير
لمفهوم الشكل العام الجماعي بان هناك
توافق في منظم وهذه التوافق لها انعكاسات
ايجابيه على السوق
23 دوله
تشكل انتاج حوالي على حسب الوضع يعني 42
43 مليون برميل كبير منه للتصدير
والحصيتهم في السوق العالميه المصدر من
البترول كبير جدا وهذا اللي ينفعك في
نهايه المطاف لانه اسعار المحليه لا تدخل
في الحسبه انما ما يتم تداوله في الاسواق
الدوليه
والمؤول عليه
والتواجد في الاسواق العالميه ايا كانت
هذه المنطقه ايضا في الاول عليك
مع كل التحديات اللي مريت مرينا فيها واما
احيانا انت تحديات سلبيه من حيث وضعت
الطلب
وحاله الركود اللي سواء الاقتصاديه او
حاله الركود في الحركه مع كوفيت الى ان
انتقلنا الان الى مرحله مختلفه في عام 22
في منطقه واحده للصين
والجوانب السياسيه ذكرت فيما يتعلق
وضع اوكرانيا ومتدائعيات الاوكراني وكل
هالحقيقه تداعيات سياسيه في المقام الاول
وايضا ما ناتج عن هذا العمل من
اجراءات اما
من جميع الاطراف
شابه في البدايه كثير من الفوضى وهذا امر
كان المشاهد
ويشوفها الان كثير من التحديات لانه هناك
ما زال حراك سياسي مدفوع
باهداف سياسيه لكنه ايضا
هي ممارسه جديده من المعالجات السياسيه
ولا كل الاقتصاديه لان اعتقد انه اثارها
ان تكون سلبيه من الناحيه الاقتصاديه او
هي مدات
لارضاء جوانب متعدده من حاله عدم اليقين
سواء في الاقتصاد العالم بشكل كلي او حتى
في ما يتعلق
ما اريد ان اصل الله هو في النهايه انه في
كل هذه المراحل
حتى هذه اللحظه
تمكنا في اوبك بلس من التعامل والتعايش مع
كل هذه المتغيرات
وان بدت الان اكثر صعوبه
بسبب التنوع التنوع الان من باب الحصر ولا
اقول من باب يعني
اطفاء شيء من العدم اليقين المفرط او حتى
اطفاء شيء من السلبيه او الاحباط لما يمكن
ان نقوم فيه لكن هو كالاتي الى الان
بوادر يعني انفتاح الاقتصاد الصيني نتيجه
التقليس منه
هذا الموضوع يحتاج وقت وبيكون فيه تردد
واغلاق
في كل الدول العالم
الوضع الاقتصادي العالمي الناشئ عن
الحقيقه افراط في
منهجيه بعض البنوك المركزيه في
توفير المالي اللي يوفر للسنوات
وعدم التردد في زياده
اسعار الفائده اللي اجت متاخره
والمعالجه متاخره ولا نجت معالجه متاخره
قوه وباكثر
مازال
البنوك المركزيه الان
يعني
المسيطر عليها هو عمليه تحكيم تضخم ايا
كان كلفه هذه
الاجراءات وان كانت سيكون لها اثار سلبيه
على النمو الاقتصادي العالم انت الان
بالاضافه الى ما هو واقع الان من مواضيع
خبر
فرضت وكلها الحقيقه لم تنتهي بعد
نتائج واضحه
بعض هذه الاجراءات مع طبق خمسه ديسمبر
من البدايات الان مشاهده انه فيه
حاله عدم يقين في الممارسه في اجراءات
متعدده لم يتم بعد
التثبت منها
وهي عمليه سوف تستمر في تحسينها او
تعديلها بما يتفق مع
المتطلبات السياسيه من غرب
هذه الادوات وانشات لاغراض السياسيه
فمدى قدرتها لتحقيق
الاغراض السياسيه ايضا
لها بعد لم يتضح بعد كذلك رده الفعل من
الجانب الاخر وما يمكن ان يقوم به
وهل ستكون مماثله بما قام به
الطرف الاخر في ما يتعلق بالغاز هل هذه
الممارسات في البترول ستكون مشابهه او
مختلفه هذا ايضا
في كل ما سويناه وهذا اللي ودي اركز عليه
ودي الجميع همم
من باب المكاشفه ومن باب ايضا لمن يسمعنا
خارج هذه الغرفه على الوطن بس خارج هذا
الوطن
لا ندخل في جوانب سياسيه ولا ندخل في
جوانب التحالفات ولا عندنا
نيه مستقبلا اننا ننتقل لاي نقله نوعيه
ايا كانت الا منظور السوء ومنظور الجانب
الاقتصادي
خير دليل على ذلك
ما قامت به المجموعه في اجتماع اكتوبر 5
اكتوبر
مع كل هذه الضغوط اللي ابتدات
من شهر اغسطس
ودي للمتابعين يرجعون تصريح سويته انا 23
اغسطس
واكد فيه على بعض الاوامر الامور الاساسيه
في امل بلاس
واكد في انه المنظومه سوف تستمر في اداء
عملها وفقا
الاقتصادي فقط
وما قامت به و سوف تقوم به في عمليه اعاده
استقلال الاسباب اخدم الاعتبار الان
نيه
وما هو متصور من قبل
ما حدث في سبتمبر بدايته اكتوبر وكده هو
عمليه
منظورين مختلفين
عليه
الجانب السياسي لحد ما وايضا
الافراط في عمليه
كما سبق في السابق يعني اذكره الجميع كان
في بدايه الازمه الاوكرانيه كان في من
يقول انه روسيا انقراض انتاج روسيا سيكون
حوالي ثلاثه مليون ثلاثه مليون
في من يقول في سبتمبر انه الطلب لا هذا
قرار خاطئه
وين احنا الان من هو المخطئ احنا في اوبر
كل هذه الامور
جد تعزز من موثوقيه القرار
اخذتها قبل امس في المقال في الفران
ودي لجميع طلع عليه شرود
هذا لا يغير في عمليه تركيزنا على الجانب
الاقتصادي وبالتالي اذا اخذنا هذا في
الاعتبار
واخذنا ايضا بكل ما تعرضت للمنظمه
والمجموعه من ضغوط في خلال الربع الاخير
هذا
انه ايضا لا يظن بلس انها ستغير
التوجهاتها وطريقه اداءها واعملها وحرصها
المستقبل خلال السنه القادمه على
المحافظه على السوق
المقام الاول وفي المقام الاخير نواجه
تحديات الان
لكن اذكي الجميع واطمن الجميع انه كما
عالجنا تحديات اكبر في ظروف اكثر صعوبه او
حتى اما الاجانب اقتصاديه او حتى لجوانب
السياسيه
لن نتردد في المعالجه في وضع السوق بما
يحافظ على
قدرنا على تنفيذ برامج
لا ننزل عندنا برامج
عندنا رؤيه
ولا ننسى انه الرؤيا لها برامج ولها كيف
في هايس ولها مستهدفات وايضا في الاف
مؤلفه من الزملاء والزميلات والعاملين في
القطاع العام والخاص يعملون لتحقيق هذه
المستهدفات
وهذا ايضا تحدي اخر انه نحنا حتى في قطاع
الطاقه كان عندنا هذا الهم الكبير لكن
عندنا
المستهدفات الاكبر اللي تجعلنا حريصين على
ان نوفق بين الجانبين بين المحافظه على
الاسواق
ومصادر الدخل الدوله وبين ايضا
تمسكنا في انه لا نقفل الجانب الداخلي
22 22 برامج
يعني زي ما بدك يعني
من ثلاث سنوات و شوي ما في مجال انا اعتقد
في كثير الان قدامي ما في مجال انك يعني
تفرط ببرامج
احنا بالنسبه لنا في الثلاث سنوات في قطاع
الطاقه كان عندنا تركه تركه معروفه كثير
من اخواني يعرف
ذاتي والجلد الجلد ذات واحنا حقيقه بحاجه
هذا بحاجه للجلد الذات والنقد الذاتي حتى
نقدر
نفوسنا
بدون تخوف بدون تردد
تشوه اللي كان عندنا على جناها الان في
قطاع يعني
يوجد ابو فيصل يعني لا بد لين اشكر مره
ثانيه على
مساعدته والزباله في وزاره
الماليه في موضوع معالجه موضوع قطاع
الكهرباء
والبنيه الاساسيه والبيئه بيئه الماليه
اللي كان يعمل فيها الانعالجت
الموضوع همم مزيج الطاقه برنامج الان
تحت التنفيذ تشوه في قطاع البترول الغاز
كيف لنا ان يكون عندنا طاقه انتاجيه من
الغاز لكن ما عندنا قدره على نقله في
مراكز
مراكز الاستهلاك وانت تعرف هذا الشعب عبد
العزيز يعني اكثر من كده التشوه ما اعرف
عندنا كان غزاره في الانتاج في او عدم
التوزيع اصلا وهذه معالجه الان موضوع
الانرجي مكس
لا اغفر اني اذكر انه من اراد ان يريد ان
يفهم يعني توجهات الطاقه في المملكه يبحث
بحث بسيط على موضوع
اقتصاد الدائره الكربوني
سيجد انه المملكه تتنفس كل المكونات هذا
الاساسيه الاربعه ليه موضوع اقتصاد
الدائره الكربوني
ودي اترك المجال للاخ محمد يشرح بعض
الجوانب اللي يعرفها انقط ثواني الكهرباء
او حتى ما سوف نقوم به عمليه
يعني نريد ان
نستهلك بترول نستهلك غاز نريد ان نستهلك
مصادر الطاقه الاخرى اللي لنا حتى تنفسيه
عاليه فيها
ونريد ان يكون مبادرين في موضوع
توفير الطاقه المستقبليه الهيدروجين ولنا
ايضا مقومات تجعلنا اكثر قدره على ان نكون
اكبر دوله مصدره للهيدروجين من نوعين
الاخضر والازرق
هذه امور
الله سبحانه عيب علينا ما نستفيد منها ولا
نعظم
استفادتنا منها
في تعزيز منهجيه تطوير
تنويع مصادر الدخل مثلا
عندنا قدرات الان تقنيه ان نحول البترول
الى منتجات البتروكيماويه اذا ما احنا
قدرنا في هذا ما نسيبه بدر
عندنا مقومات ان نحول الطاقه المتجدده الى
هيدروجين
ونملك يعني بالركض انه احنا اقل كلفه في
كمون دوله منتجه للطاقه المتجدده نفس
الشيء عندنا يعني
شكرا سمو الاميره اعتقد انه اليوم اللي
احنا شاهدناه في القطاع الخاص
من كلمه لوزير الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان في جلسه الحوار الثانيه
لملتقى الميزانيه السعوديه
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
فرنسا تتغلبوا على انجلترا وتواجه المنتخب
المغربي الاربعاء المقبل في نصف نهائي
المونديال
في دنيا القوات الاوكرانيه بقصف مركز
المدينه بعشرين صاروخ جراد واوضحت السلطات
التي نصبتها روسيا في مدينه ملتل بول ذات
الموقع الاستراتيجي ان اوكرانيا هاجمت
المدينه جنوب الشرقيه البلاد مساء امس
فيما اضافت السلطات المواليه لموسكو انا
هجوم منصور عن مقتل شخصين واصابه 10 اخرين
في حين قال رئيس البلديه ان عشرات
المهاجرين لكم وذكر الحاكم الذي عينتهم
موسكو للجزء الروسي من منطقه زازا
الى اهدافها اكد مسؤولون اوكرانيون انقطاع
الكهرباء عن جميع مرافق البنيه التحتيه
غير الحيويه في مدينه اوديس الساحليه
بجنوب اوكرانيا بعد اطلاق روسيا طائرات
مسيره لقاف منشئتين للطاقه مما ادى الى
انقطاع الكهرباء اكثر
في اليوم شخص في ما وصف الرئيس فولتمير
زيليننسكي الوضع في منطقه اوديسا بانه صعب
للغايه
من عمان ينضم الينا المحلل العسكري لواء
محمد الثلجي اهلا بك سعاده اللواء اذا قصف
عنيف مضاد للقوات الاوكرانيه على اراضي
روسيه همم كيف تقيم هذا هذه الاستراتيجيه
التي تنتهجها اوكرانيا حاليا
همم
لمناطق روسيه ومناطق ايضا اوكرانيه تقع
تحت سيطره القوات الروسيه بات يتخطى حاجز
المواجهه المباشره مع القوات الروسيه التي
دابت اوكرانيا على تبنيه منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب همم هذا هذا هذا التخطي يعني همم
يتجاوز كما ذكرت يعني الى اهداف من شانها
اهداف اثر معنوي واثر نفسي كبير جدا وهذا
ياتي ضمن الاطار محاوله القوات الاوكرانيه
لنقل وتيره الصراع وسير العمليات ربما الى
مستوى اخر في مناطق هو في مناطق ربما لم
تكون مشلوله ايضا في اساسا وبعيد عن الحرب
لم تكن مجنونه وبعيده عن الحرب هذا من شان
كما ذكرت ان ينقل الصراع الى مستوى اثر
المناطق المستهدفه سيدتي هي مناطق قريبه
من خطوط التماس وهي تقع في ما بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه مدينه بول
بالذاتيه مدينه ذات ثقل صناعي مهم جدا وهي
محور همم يعني همم كما ذكرت محور نقل رئيس
جدا وباسيطر على هذا هذه المدينه يعني
سينها الخط الدفاع الروسي حتى خيار شعله
وبالتالي تنفتح الطريق امام القوات
الاوكرانيه ولكن هذا من شانه ان يشير الى
الى امور اخرى الامر الاول هنالك النيه
لدى القوات الاوكرانيه تتجه وليست
اوكرانيا فقط يعني ربما تكون ايضا الدول
الناعمه لاوكرانها في نقل المعركه الى
داخل الاراضي الروسيه والى داخل عمق
الروسي وهذا مدفوع بسبب
سعاده اللواء نقل المعركه الى داخل الروسي
وهذا كانت تحذر منه روسيا منذ البدايه
بشكل واضح وصريح بان ما تم ذلك ستستخدم
وقت تلجا الى النووي
بالضبط سيدتي نعم انا اشير هنا يعني الى
بعض امور ماذا هذا له مقدمات يعني اذا
لاحدتي سيدتي الاسبوع الماضي وقبله كان
هنالك يعني امتداد اليد الاوكرانيه الى
داخل العمق الروسي وبمسافات تتجاوز ال 500
كيلو متر وايضا الى الى مسافات تتجاوز
ال23 كم في الجنوب الشرقي استهداف
المطارات والتي يعني هي مطارات مخصصه
للطائرات
الذي ادى الى هذه ربما المكاسب الاوكرانيه
ضد الروسيه ما الذي جعل الموازين تختلف
اولا سيدتي هنالك يعني ربما الخطه
الاوكرانيه يعني هي خطه يبدو انها طويله
الامد وخطه محكمه ويبدو انها تعالج نقاطا
مهمه ونقاطا حساسه يعني تؤثر بشكل كبير
جدا على الناحيه المعنويه والناحيه
النفسيه
سواء على المستوى العسكري والمستوى
السياسي في اتخاذ اجراءات ليست في العثبان
لم يكن في حسبان القياده السياسيه
والقياده العسكريه الروسيه ان تقوم
اوكرانيا بمهاجمه هذه المطارات والتي هي
مخصصه للطائرات التي تحمل الصواريخ
النوويه والقاذفات النوويه وبالتالي هذا
ربما هذا ربما هذا يفسر لاجراءات التي تلت
هذا الاستهدا في ان هناك تحقيقا قد تم
فتحه وانه هنالك اجراءات جديده القوات
الروسيه في حمايه القواعد العسكريه وايضا
تعزيز الاجراءات الحمايه للمناطق الحدوديه
والمناطق التي تقع ضمن الاستهدافات
الاوكرانيه بفتح
تدريب سكان المحليين على اجراءات الحمايه
وهذا لم يكن موجودات الحرب
الروسي المتوقع على المجريات العسكريه
التي تحدث الان على ارض المعركه
همم هذا سيدتي انا يعني اولا الاسترداف
الاوكراني هو ردا على على استهداف وديشا
وديشا يعني هي همم منذ يومين في ظلام دامس
وربما جاء هذا الاستئناف وردا على ما قامت
به القوات الاوكرانيه ولكن اذا ما قامت
القوات الاوكرانيه مدعومه طبعا بالاسلحه
الغربيه ومدعومه في الاستخبارات الغربيه
ومدعومه في كل ما يمكنها من الوصول الى
العمق الروسي سيكون هنالك اجراءات يعني
روسيه رادعه ولا يمكن الحديث عن السداد
العمق الروسي بدون تخيل رد روسي
صعب بالضبط
كبيره جدا في اوكرانيا وهذا شيء شكل ضطانا
على الدائمين الغربيين سواء كان بالمطالب
ايه ده التي يحتاجها الاوكرانيين او ايضا
بثقل اللجوء الانسان هو الذي سيفرض واقعا
جديدا ديموغرافيه جديده في في مقابل الضغط
او الضربه المضاد الاوكراني على روسيا
هناك ايضا الضغط على الاوروبيين وعلى
المواطنون هناك شكرا لك من عمان المحلل
العسكريه اللواء محمد الثلجي لهذه
المداخله
بينما يجري الاتحاد الاوروبي مفاوضات
تحديد سقف سعر الغاز محولا التوصل الاتفاق
يرضي الجميع على الاطراف بعض الدول اعترضت
مشاهدينا على السعر الذي تتم مناقشته
مطالبه بتخفيضه بشكل اكبر
عصفوراني بحجر واحد عقوبات تضغط على روسيا
وتخفيف اعداء عن المواطن الاوروبي هذا ما
يحاول الاتحاد الاوروبي للقيام به بتحديد
سقف لسعر الغاز في اوروبا ويجتمع وزراء
الطاقه للتوصل الى سعر ثابت يخفف وطات
ازمه الطاقه التي اجتاحت القاره العجوز
كزوبعه غير متوقعه اثر الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا الا ان الدول الاعضاء ليست كلها
محشوره في الزاويه الضيقه للغازي الروسي
بعضها تعتمد على الغاز الروسي بشكل اكبر
من الاخر ما يجعل وضعها اسوا من دول اخرى
فلا مقارنه بين المانيا التي تستورد 55%
من غازها من روسيا وفرنسا التي اكتفت
بسبعه في المئه فقط معتمده على مصادر اخرى
كالنرويج
ما اداب اثنتي عشره دوله من دول الاعضاء
الى المطالبه بخفض كبير لسقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي يتفاوض عليه
[موسيقى]
لتبقى العقده الاكبر في الاتحاد الان ليس
الرقم بل ايجاد اليه لارضاء جميع الاعضاء
في ظل اعتماد الكتله على قاعده الاجماع
التي لا تحتمل اعتراض عضو واحد
عمليه تحديد سقف السعر تغضب موسكو
كان قد صرح ان بلاده سترفض بيع منتجاتها
من المحروقات لاي دوله تطبق السقف السعري
شتاء بارد دائما في اوروبا الا ان الحرب
الروسيه الساخنه زادت من برودته بالرغم من
ان الدول الاوروبيه مثل المانيا تؤكد ان
مخزوناتها تكفيها حتى نهايه الفصل الا
انها تشدد على ترشيد الاستهلاك اذا عمر
العربيه
فرنسا حامله اللقب اقصت المنتخب
الانجليزيه ضمن الدوري الربع النهائي
فرنسا ستواجه المنتخب المغربي في نصف
النهائي وذلك بعد ان استطاع اسود الاطلس
للفوز على البرتغال والصعود التاريخي
للمربع الذهبي من كاس العالم
الى تقرير الرياضي مع زميله ليليان تنوري
تحيه الرياضيات
[تصفيق]
اصبح المغرب اول منتخب عربي او افريقي يصل
الى نصف نهائي
سيلعب المغرب الذي كان يشارك في دوله
ثمانيه لكاس العالم لاول مره في تاريخه
سيلعب امام منتخب فرنسا
اه يعني
نصف النهائي في كاس العالم اتمنى ان لا
نكون اخر منتخب من القاره يصل لهذا الدور
بالنسبه لحاله الصحيه سنرى غدا الفحوصات
وان كان يجب ان العب بقدم واحده في نصف
النهائي فساقوم بذلك
الفوز بالمباراه
احنا بالنسبه للخلطه اللي قلت احنا احنا
عائله والحمد لله كتشوفها في همم في
الملعب لما بيتصاب لك لاعب والحمد لله
بيدخل الاخر بيؤدي بشكل جيد وهذا هو هذا
هو الفريق اللي الحمد لله بيحقق نتائج
كبيره الحمد لله
مبروك على
كاس العالم
المغرب كما تغنوا باسماء اللاعبين والمدرب
وليد الرجراجي الذي قاد المنتخب لهذا
الانجاز التاريخي
الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انا جانب الاخر اعتلت الحسره هو الحزن جوه
الجماهير البرتغاليه التي شهدت منتخب
بلادها وهو يودع البطوله على يد المنتخب
المغربي بعد الخساره بهدف من دون رضوى تعد
هذه البطوله الاخيره لكريستيانو رونالدو
الذي علقت عليه جماهير العديد من الامال
في السنوات الماضيه لمساعده منتخب بلاده
للظفر باغلى بطوله في العالم على مستوى
المنتخب
وصل المنتخب الفرنسي طريقه نحو الحفاظ على
لقبه بطلا لكاس العالم بعد فوزه على
المنتخب الانجليزي بهدفين مقابل هدف
واحدتاهل نصف نهائي لمواجهه المنتخب
المغربي سدد شاوميني تسديده قويه سكنت
شباك المنتخب الانجليزي تقدم به منتخب
بلاده في الشوط الاول قبل ان يعيد هاري
كين انجلترا الى المباراه لتسجيل هدف
التعادل من ضربه جزاء وتقدم المنتخب
الفرنسي مجددا بهدف سجله وهدافه الاول
اوليفياجيرو وسنحط فرصه اخرى
ثانيه من ضربه جزاء لكنه سددها فوق
العارضه لتنتهي المباراه بفوز فرنسا وتكتب
نهايه رحله منتخب الاسود الثلاثه في
المنطقه
[تصفيق]
كانت هذه ابرز اخبار المونديال شكرا
لمتابعتكم تحياتي
من القاهره ينضم الينا ان نقدر رضي
الرياضي احمد جلال اهلا بك سيد احمد اذا
فوز وصفات بالتاريخي للمنتخب المغربي هل
هذا الفوز لاول فريق عربي يؤهل ان الصف
النهائي من بطولات كاس العالم هل تاخر هذا
الوصول ام اتى في وقته
هناك دروس كثيره مستفاده من المنتخب
المغربي كل يوم نكتشف الجديد هناك على
المستوى الفني تحدثنا عنه كثيرا على
المستوى الدوافع
ظهر راجل بشكل مغير اللحمه تزداد يوما بعد
يوم كان هناك افتقاده لهذا الامر في
المنتخبات شمال افريقيا بس اثناء المنتخب
المصري خلال الفتره الماضيه الان نجد
اللحمه تزداد مع المنتخب المغربي الروابط
العائليه لها دور كبير جدا ربما على بعضها
جان يعني انسانيه على الهام مش لكنه مؤثر
بشكل كبير في اداء ولحمه اللاعبين راينا
التقرير راينا فمن يتحدث
نعم نعم انا اتحدث ان ان اللاعبون
تعاملونا كعائله هذا امر مهم للغايه لا
راينا كيف يتم خلق الدوافع راينا ان
المنتخب المغربي لديه الشخصيه لديه القدره
على التقدم الى المزيد ياسين بونو الذي
قلت اكثر من مره انه سيكون رجل المرحله
امس حصل على رجل المباراه للمره الثانيه
لكنه اهدى هدفه او اهدى جائزته الى يوسف
النصيري الذي احرز هدفا من من الخيال هذا
الهدف يعني صعد به وارتقى مترين و80 سم
تقريبا هذا رقم لم يحدث الا مع كريستيانو
رونالدو الذي تفوق بشكل طفيف على هذه
القفزه اثنين متر 80 احرز الهدف رائعه
لاعبون همم لديهم القدرات لكن تتخيل ان
المنتخب المغربي من ضمن الاربعه الكبار
ارقام هي الافضل المنتخب المغربي لم تهتز
الشباكه بس هو بهدف الوحيد بل وكان من
نيران صديقه من خطا لنجم كبير وهنائف ولكن
مع ذلك المنتخب المغربي ظل متماسكا امام
الاسباني وسلم متماسكا امام البرتغاليين
وصلنا متماسكا امام البلجيكيين تحقق له
الفوز بقدرات لاعبين لم يكتفي فقط بالدفاع
بل كانت له شخصيته في الهجوم هذا امر يؤكد
ان المباراه القادمه اذا كنا كنا نقول ان
المنتخب الفرنسي هو بطل العالم فان
المنتخب المغربي لديه الدوافع نحن الان
امام الاربعه الكبار ليست هناك مباراه
سهله ليس هناك كبير وصغير المنتخب الفرنسي
اذا كانت لديه حصوص كما يتحدث البعض الان
العالم كله وليس العرب فقط يتحدثون عن هذه
المواجهه ستكون بينديه كامله ومتكافؤ كبير
بين الطرفين
تحديدا بين المنتخب المغربي والفرنسي
السيد احمد وبالنظر الى الاداء الاستثناء
للمنتخب المغربي والاداء الفريق الفرنسي
ما توقعاتك لهذه المواجهه
ولماذا لا نفوز فعالتها تونس وفازت على
فرنسا نعم كانت التوافق المنتخب الفرنسي
اقل نعم كان هناك بعض اللاعبين على دكه
الاحتياط مثل عثمان ديمبلي وكليان مبابي
وانطونيو جريزمان ولكن جميعهم شاركوا في
النصف الاخير من المباراه ونجح تونس في
الفوز بلقاء بهدف الى شيء لماذا لا تكررها
المغرب وهي قد فعلت المزيد في هذه البطوله
نحن الان امام منتخب يستطيع ان يصنع ما هو
اكثر من ان نقول عليه المستحيل اهو الان
في مرحله الاعجاز لماذا لا يحقق المزيد هم
قادرون على ذلك باذن الله
ونتمنى ان يعود المنتخب المغربي بالكاس
بين يديه من القاهره الناقد الرياضي احمد
جلال شكرا جزيلا لك
اعلنت الخارجيه الامريكيه عن توجه وفد
رفيع المستوى الى الصين يتراسه مساعد وزير
الخارجيه لشؤون شرق اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
دانيال كريبترنيك وكبيره مديري مجلس الامن
القومي لشؤون الصين وتايوان لورا روزنبرج
وستمحدوا مهمتهما لزياره وزير الخارجيه
للصين اوائل العام 23
وبحسب الخارجيه الامريكيه فان الوفد سيزور
اضافه للصين كلا من كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان
تعرضت امال الرئيس الامريكي السابق للوصول
الى ولايه ثانيه في البيت الابيض اللي
ضربه قويه زعيم الحزب الجمهوري يواجه حمله
الابتعاد والتخلي عنه من كبار مناصره مع
متاعب سياسيه ترافقها اخرى ماليه المزيد
في التقرير التالي
من فضيحه الى مطب ومن مطب الى فضيحه هذا
حال الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
الذي تعرضت اعماله في الوصول الى البيت
الابيض لولايه ثانيه لضربه قويه
فترم كان يراهن على مد المحافظين في
الانتخابات النصفيه لكنه تعثر مع سقوطه
عدد غير قليل من مرشحه
الانتكاسه وحملت سلسله ردات اهتزازيه دفعت
شخصيات المحافظه من العيار الثقيل الى
التخلي عنه محمله ترامب مسؤوليه الهزيمه
لكن ترامب المثيره للجدل احتفظ بمفاجاه
سيئه اخرى عشان مع مغني الراب كان يوست
المتهم بمعاداه الساميه
لانقاص من الانتقادات الجمهوريه من عيار
مثير للسخريه
عكست حجم الاستياء داخل المعسكر الجمهوريه
ولمن اعتقد ان متاعب الرئيس الخامس
والاربعين للولايات المتحده انتهت اخرج
ترامب من جعبته مفاجاه سيئه ثالثه او
رابعه
اتهامات التزوير الانتخابي خطاب واتهامات
باتت شخصيات ثقيله في الحزب الجمهوري
بنفسها عنها ليس هي فحسب ايضا هناك عدد
كبير من كبار منحيه احجم عن دعم ترجيحه في
تاثير بدا واضحا على ترامب الذي يراهن
مؤيدوه على مفاجاه قد تقلب الامور لصالحه
واجبر الرئيس السابق على احجام عن اي تجمع
انتخابي خارج مقر اقامته في مره لاجوبي
ولايه فلوريدا منذ ان اعلن ترشحه اذا
متعبه سياسيه ترافقها ايضا اخرى ماليه مع
خضوع ترامب لعدد من التحقيقات حول اداره
ارشفه وكذلك في شؤونه الماليه في نيويورك
انقلكم الان مشاهدينا الى اخبار الاقتصاد
مع كلارا
شكرا فاطمه
مشاهدين اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد نحدث اذا
ارقام اسواق الخليج وهذه تداولات سوق
الاسهم السعوديه على ارتفاع بصفر فاصل
واحد بالمئه لا ننسى على بدال الاسبوع
الماضي سجلنا تراجعات في سوق الاسهم
السعوديه كانت الاعلى بين اسواق الخليج
ووصلت الى حدود الخمسه في البيئه اليوم
الصوره افضل الارتفاعات بصفر فاصل واحد
بالمئه الى هذه المستويات
10,261 النقطه لانه القناطر اذا مشاهدينا
على بعض الاسهم التي نتبعها اليوم في
السوق والاسهم الاكثر همم نشاطا ايضا قبل
هذه الاسهم عليها اخبار من ضمن اسمنتيون
بواساهم فيه تراجع اليوم بصفر فاصل واحد
بالمئه تعلن عن توزيع توزيعات النصف
الثاني 75 هلله لسه معنا نصف الثاني
بالمقارنه مع 75 لا لا ايضا وزعتها عن
النصف الاول بالتالي هنا نتحدث عن عائد
للتوزيعات بحدود 4.5%
همم للسهم هذا يعني عم بحتسبه على اغلاقات
يوم الخميس ينساب تعلن الشركه بانه
الاعلان عن نتائج الثانويه سوف يكون
بالاسبوع الثالث من شهر فبراير ساسكو تعلن
عن بدايه تشغيل المحطاتها على طريق
المدينه المنوره وينبع السريع حجم
الاستثمار 16 مليون ريال عبر تموله الشركه
عبر تمويلات بنكيه والاثر المالي الايجابي
تتوقعه ابتداء من الربع الاول معدنيه
السهم مستقر تعلن عن انشاء مصنع لجدل
الاسلاك الحديديه بتكلفه ب30 مليون ريال
بمملكه البحرين تمويل ذاتي وايضا قرود
ولكن لم تعطينا معلومات اضافيه حول هذا
المشروع وصعب يعلن عن اعاده شراء مليون
سهم من السومه بغرض تخصيصه للموظفين
لبرامج حوافز طويله الاجل سهم اليوم فيه
بعض اثر الراجحي الاهلي على ارتفاع الاهلي
المكاسب الاثنين بالمائه الاهلي يعلن عن
اكتمال
ااا صفقه كريد سويس هو يشتري 9.9% من
كريدي سويس بعد ان اقدم البنك السويسري
على رفع راس ماله معادن 1.3% من الارتفاع
اليوم ارامكو ايضا 0.2% من المكاسب ماذا
عن الاسهم الاخرى الاكثر ارتفاعا شمس اكوا
باور والورق اكاديميه التعلم ايضا اثنين
ونص بالمئه من المكاسب اما الاكثر تراجعا
اتهام التي اعدت للتداول المشروع السعوديه
متطوره ايضا على خسائر باربع فاصل ثمانيه
بالبيئه مشاهدينا قبل ان نختم همم نظره
نذكر باسعار النفط التي سجل التراجعات
اسبوعيه كانت قاسيه اكثر من 10% خسائر
دبليو اي وبراند عم نتحدث عن اكبر تراجعات
اسبوعيا منذ اغسطس على براند وسبب الرئيسي
وراء ذلك المخاوف انه التباطل الاقتصادي
ممكن ان يؤثر على الطلب على النف على كلان
بالطبع انا اقعد معكم تبعا لتحديث هذه
الارقام لن اعود الان الك فاطمه شكرا لارا
عينت رئيسه هروء دينا بلورات حكومه جديده
برئاسه المدعي العام السابق رغم تصاعد
الاحتجاجات في البلاد للمطالبه باجراء
انتخابات جديده وذلك مشاهدينا بعض الاطاحه
بالرئيس السابق هيدرو كاستيلو وعيانه
بولورات المدعي العام السابق هيدرو انجلو
رئيسا للوزراء والدبلوماسيه انا سيسيليا
وزيره الخارجيه المتظاهرون يطالبون بحل
الكونجرس واجراء انتخابات الديمقراطيه
ودستور جديد
خدمات المسح الجيولوجيه الامريكيه عن
انخفاض انبعاثات الحمم والغازات البركانيه
في اكبر بركان نشط في العالم في موانا في
جزر هاواي الامر الذي ادى الى خفض مستوى
التنبيه للبركان الى مستوى الساعه من
مستوى التحدير السابق حيث اقتصرت الحمم
على منطقه صغيره
[موسيقى]
في نهايه النشره نذكر بالعناوين
العفو الدوليه تقول ان الامن الايرانيه
قتل 44 طفلا خلال ثلاثه اشهر من
الاحتجاجات
سلطات ودنيتك المواليه لموسكو تقول انك في
استهدفت مركز المدينه ب 20 صاروخا من نوع
جراند
واشنطن تعلن عن توجه وافترافيه على
المستوى الى الصين ضمن جوله تشمل كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان
فرنسا تتغلب على انجلترا وتواجه المنتخب
المغربي الاربعاء المقبل في نصف نهائي
المونديال
شكرا للمتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]